on ne couche pas pendant les deux heures
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle à sa
reposent de belles filles alors est-ce
que légaliser les drogues douces ça vous
semble une idée stupéfiante où il vous
semble stupéfiants qu'on n'est pas déjà
fait alors là jean marie bigard pense
que
comme de toute façon tout le monde le
fait ouais ben ça changerait pas grand
chose en fait
et donc que tout le monde se bat
toujours pour la légalisation de
marijuana blanc fait c'est fait c'est ce
que vous de oui voilà à peu près à peu
près c'est ce que jean marie bigard
pense oui c'est ce pardon excusez moi
alors on va passer maintenant au
commerce du sexe qui est un sujet qui
est nouveau pour vous est ce que vous
êtes pour la réouverture des maisons
closes ou pour la fermeture des boîtes à
partouzes nom alors je suis alors alain
delon d'ailleurs démarqué par sa
pareille pareil que pour la première
question jean marie bigard et pour le
cul existe tout bon de le pratiquer
il ya des bordels absolument partout et
les quartiers entiers de paris où il est
possible évidemment de deux squats et ça
coûte des fois un petit peu cher mais on
boit un verre avec une jeune fille à
moitié dénudée jean marie bigard l'a
fait déjà
jean marie vien s'est aperçu que
derrière le petit rideau la bouteille de
champagne passé 2500 val jean vigué il
fallait mais qu'il fallait enfin en fer
en fallait en boire au moins 3 ou 4
avant de jean marie billa pense que
c'est cher est ce que jean marie bigard
pense que quand on va dans un endroit
comme ça et puis qu'on est derrière le
rideau avec la jeune fille dénudée et
qu'on a bu trois bouteilles de champagne
on peut encore la sauter la fille
jean marie bigard pense que c'est servir
dans de se retrouver avec des
agriculteurs qui sont allés au salon wii
et puis
de trois quinquagénaires rouge aux
anciens de la cgt ils sont l'oeil
jean marie bigard s'est fait comme tout
le monde piégée ouais bien sûr parce que
quand jean marie bigard est arrivé à
paris oui jean marie bigard est passé
devant et d'innombrables bar avec des
jeunes filles avec la moitié des danish
en a l'air et puis jean marie bigard est
rentré oui il est rentré il a dit est-ce
que je peux boire un verre et
immédiatement plusieurs jeunes filles se
sont représentés à lui alors que jean
marie bigard n'était pas connue encore
qu'il n'était pas jean marie bigard
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
donc jean marie bigard s'est fait baiser
la gueule comme tout le monde mais c'est
vrai que c'est un endroit existe et donc
sont ouverts dont ils sont ouverts oui
hélas il est en fête
ça pourrait coûter moins cher bien tweet
si on sort gay si on s'organisait un peu
bien jean marie bigard est un petit peu
déstabilisés par pas vos questions à
quelle santé alors bon on va passer à
des choses plus simples jean marie
bigard votre conception du luxe est ce
que vous préférez boire du coca cola
dans un verre en cristal ou du petrus
dans un gobelet en plastique
jean marie bigard préfère le petrus quel
que soit le contenant je préfère boire
du petrus même dans un gobelet en bien
absolument d'accord
est ce que pour garder et celle que vous
aimez vous êtes prêt à l'enfermer dans
un palais ou à la sortir dans des clubs
échangistes a donc on retourne dans le
club échanges mais c'est jean-marie
sinon jean marie bigard pense que
l'enfermer dans un palais évidemment
c'est une solution qui est très facile
mais comme jean marie bigard est un
combattant
jean-marie vigueur peut éventuellement
penser qu à bout de souffle et s'il
emmenait sa femme d'un club échangiste
je pense que jamais avait garé sera un
peu gêné de voir peut-être sa femme se
faire pénétrer par le rouge au de la
sécurité tout à l'heure et donc
jean marie bigard ça rappelle cette
blague et jean marie bigard gafsa et qui
dit à son pote ça te dirait de venir
dans une partouze dit ouais et idiot
serait combien m'a dit si tu viens avec
ta femme sera 3 bien qu est ce que vous
serez plus choquant l'interdiction des
mariages homos ou la banalisation des
divorces hétéro
oh la la jean marie bigard est très
choquée par cette question c'est une
originalité encore une fois
l'homosexualité c'est bien qu'elle soit
original donc il faut pas la mettre dans
un concept normal je mange et puis de
nord banalisée banaliser les divorces
hétéros les divorcés et héros bat jean
marie bigard pense que c'est déjà fait
on a pas mal d'analysés mais jamais un
bigard rossy pense encore une fois que
on se donne une bonne conscience en
déchirant fait un papier avec quelqu'un
mais je pense que le désengagement qu'on
a avec une personne de la de déchirer un
papier qui est un contrat de mariage ils
pensent que ce n'est pas une chose très
très jolie de toute façon et jean marie
bigard pense que
c'est mieux de rester sur ses positions
et jean marie bigard ne divorce pas
voilà jean marie bigard par exemple de
divorce par exemple
alors pour faire du social est ce que
vous demanderiez les salaires vous
diminuerez le temps de travail alors là
jean marie bigard voudrait dire un
message à l'ensemble de la planète
c'est que le travail à nara pas de plus
en plus y en a de moins en moins
l'erreur de moins en moins de travail
donc il faut se faire à l'idée qu'on
travaillera de moins en moins ça serait
donc il vous oui mais il faut se faire à
l'idée qu'il y aura une
ce sera un luxe de travailler et de dire
on travaille pour l'ensemble de la
planète et toutes les grosses
entreprises qui travaillent avec des
machines qui ne sont pas syndiqués à la
cgt qui n'agite pas de banderole le
matin non mais on appuie sur un bouton
elles font de travail de dix personnes
dont il ya toujours de moins en moins de
travail les grosses entreprises vont
gagner de plus en plus d'argent et donc
il va falloir à un moment que nous on
s'occupe autrement que par le travail
peut être en s'occupant ce sont faire
peut-être en s'occupant de son prochain
peut-être que on se spiritual ''sera
puisque c'est ce qui a été prédit par
tout le monde depuis des centaines
d'années
c'est qu'on me présenter avec sa
plaisante pas
[Musique]
il n'a jamais entendu 400 personnes dans
un achat chanter le home qui est le
sujet là bas et le son de l'univers et
c'est magnifique c'est la sueur c'est le
seul son qui qui qu'on devrait entendre
chaque fois qu'on a un peu de repos on
peut leur faire pendant les missions
qu'on se tourne vers son soin way
intérieure et je propose qu'on fasse
pour la mission comme ça certains
nombres de pose absolument un s'ils
pouvaient me faire penser en régime
c'est quoi c'est pas trop mon truc dans
ce n'est pas jean marie bigard n'aime
pas quand vous vous foutez de la gueule
ils ensemble village
bien alors jean-marie un regard qu
avez-vous le sentiment d'avoir le plus
souvent ratés dans votre vie votre
chance d'être un ou d occasion de la
fermer
jean marie bigard ne rate pas de chance
il ne rate pas de train non plus jean
marie bigard est à l'heure tout le temps
il ne rate pas le train le train attend
jean marie bigard bc c'est jean marie
bigard jean mabire pour ce qui est de
fermer sa gueule des gens d'affaires
mère aurait eu des occasions de fermer
sa gueule mais il a pensé que ce serait
dommage pour l'ensemble des êtres
humains de la planète qui attendent
l'avis de jean marie bigard
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus